last time you were here you were talking
you were here to promote the premiere of
Legion on FX nobody you know had much of
an idea of like what's this show gonna
be like people loved the show and now
there's all this Emmy buzz about the
show how excited are you about this I'm
really excited yeah yeah I love working
on that show and I'm just happy that
people like it mm-hmm
yeah I don't know I've never been buzzed
about or whatever so you never had buzz
surrounding you no yeah we've all had
buzz at one point I had buzz in like
1994 I had some yeah I heard some
distinct buzzing in 94 and then it just
turned out it was bees and it just
acting like an idiot I want to ask you
about this this is a pervy question but
that's what I do
for a legion it was necessary for you to
get your body molded in what plastic
what do they do rubber know what is it
no I don't know it's like weird
I think it's plaster maybe okay yeah
they did like a whole like a half body
cast because my body is in I like died
inside of a wall or something so I'm
like half outside of a wall so they
basically like covered in my top torso
and like plaster I guess know how freaky
is that how do you breathe a lot of
people when they go through something
like that for special effects and I've
had to do it to they you freaked out
because you feel claustrophobic you feel
like you can't breathe how did you
handle that I really loved it I
why did you I could see saying I didn't
mind it but why would you why would you
actively love it I don't know I'm
honestly I'm not claustrophobic
I like being in small confined spaces
and I like the feeling of like being
crushed and if I had to choose a way to
die not that I don't know that I have to
but you know when people play that game
like would you want to drown or get
killed by shark or whatever I usually
say like I would be suffocated because I
feel like you get squeezed and then I
think your body falls asleep and then
you die peacefully
I don't know I don't know yeah I think
that's important you say I don't know I
don't know I think if you ask people
that have been suffocated they will say
not a good deal that's not the way to go
I would like to fall in a vat of caramel
and then suffocated three out of ten
yeah I know exactly no effort you just
said but and I loved it but you said
nine weird things in one sentence all
right but you like to be crushed if I
was a dog I would wear those thunder
coats what did they call I don't know
what's a thunder coat help me out here
like it's yeah it's like a compression
jacket and it makes them feel secure
yeah right anyway that swaddling a baby
will make it feel secure
right big old baby that was sort of
saucy the way you said it I'm a big old
baby and I want to be swaddled that's
like a personal ad that you would put in
the paper
I need my dipey change oh you have just
opened yourself up yeah you realize
really hard to the inner you said this
on TV and are all these panic freaks out
there I like being held in a confined
space dressed like a baby slowly crushed
and I want to be suffocated you can't
say that suck
seems my typing I want my type you
change that I'm with I get that
you